monsieur lestinator vous avez mantionné
l'énergie et notamment les
recommandations du président qui ont
créé comme vous le savez parce que les
prix de marché immédiat sont plus élevés
que les prix futurs donc effectivement
il faut pas se caler sur les prix de
marché immédiat et notre objectif c'est
de faire baisser les prix de l'énergie
je crois que
[Musique]
je crois que j'ai oublié une question
sur les visages j'y reviendrai je vous
prie de m'excuser
les trucs de faire baisser les prix de
l'énergie et c'est vraiment la direction
dans laquelle que le que prend le
Conseil européen laissez-moi juste vous
rappeler que la présidence check a dit
qu'elle réunirait autant de conseils
d'énergie extraordinaires que nécessaire
pour arriver à cet objectif j'espère que
nous aurons quelque chose pour le 20 21
octobre mais je suis confiante que nous
aurons quelque chose
de toute façon
dans ces mesures et comme je
lui disais tout à l'heure il y a à la
fois la réduction de la demande
je voudrais répéter que c'est important
parce que si on enlève de la pression
sur la demande avec une offre constante
pardonnée économiste qui est en moi mais
ça fait baisser les prix et notamment
les prix de marché puisque le signal est
et tout de suite perçu par par les
acteurs de marché donc ça c'est la
première chose baisser la consommation
et les stockages en tout ce qui concerne
la deuxième chose je le rappelais tout à
l'heure il y a effectivement les mesures
de solidarité pour s'assurer que nous
aurons tous ce qu'il faut cet hiver et
de diversification des
approvisionnements et aujourd'hui les
discussions qui sont à l'oeuvre elles
concernent effectivement directement la
baisse des prix donc il y a plusieurs
façons de faire ça et toutes ces façons
et ses options sont à l'étude d'où la
confusion que certains ont pu soulever
parfois on peut mettre des plafonds sur
les prix du gaz importer de Russie nous
l'avons fait sur le pétrole nous pouvons
le faire avec eux des corridors ça veut
dire que au lieu de mettre un prix fixe
on va se situer dans une ligne parce
qu'évidemment tout le monde n'a pas les
mêmes contrats européens nous pouvons
faire la même chose discuter la même
chose avec la Norvège mais aussi avec
d'autres fournisseurs tels que les
États-Unis dans la mesure où nous aurons
des prix qui seront suffisants pour
toujours attirer du gaz et notamment du
gaz naturel liquéfié en Europe puisque
la concurrence avec l'Asie comme vous le
savez va être forte donc ça c'est sur
les plafonds sur les prix du gaz importé
on peut également mettre des plafonds
sur les les prix de gros dans l'Union
européenne à nouveau pour faire baisser
les prix du gaz évidemment ça ça va
demander des subventions puis il y a le
troisième sujet qui est celui qui est
connu sous le nom du de mécanisme
ibérique dans lequel on baisse le prix
du gaz par rapport au prix de marché
grâce à une subvention d'État et donc le
prix de l'électricité fabriquée à partir
de ce gaz baisse naturellement ça
n'aurait pas beaucoup d'intérêt de le
faire en France uniquement que nous
produisons très peu d'électricité à
partir de gaz comme vous le savez c'est
pour ça que nous portons une solution en
européen qui aurait l'avantage de faire
baisser les prix pour tous les Européens
et donc éventuellement aussi les prix de
l'électricité que nous importons
pardonnez-moi je lis dans les yeux du
cinéma que j'étais un peu longue sur ce
sujet
merci
[Musique]